华为提出的淘定率在先进制程缩小
越来越困难的状况下
舍弃电晶体密度改用时间长数来判断制程进步的程度
其实是一个很好的观点
因此华为的淘定率确实有创新之处
只是文章的后面
为了要
各位曲波科技教师的观众朋友大家好
我是曲波
上个礼拜呢
我们拍了一个短片介绍华为的淘定率
以及逻辑折叠基本的概念
在影片里面
我有提过华为的逻辑折叠确实有创新之处
但是呢我并没有详细说明到底哪里创新
同时在短片的后面我也提到
华为计算等效电晶体密度的方式只是定义的不同
因此没有办法跟其他的晶圆场直接做比较
到底啊
华为提出的超定律和逻辑折叠有什么创新之处呢
今天我们就来和大家谈谈这个题目
首先我们介绍摩尔定律放缓先进封装登场
再来我们和大家谈谈
传统先进封装采用的是2D平面设计思维
而华为的掏定律细立度细制裁
IP是采用3D的立体设计思维
再来我们介绍逻辑折叠的验证案例和制成挑战
以及华为先进的混合建核技术
需求是创新之母
再来我们和大家谈谈逻辑折叠
从概念走向真实晶片的系统挑战
以及逻辑折叠的散热管理与电源递送
还有逻辑折叠的晶片密度改善
性能和能源效率提升
最后我们和大家谈谈逻辑折叠的成本和良率效益
首先呢
这个简报就和大家谈到摩尔定律放缓
先进封装登场
传统的半导体制成眼镜提供了萎缩增长
也就是电晶体越做越小
已经没有办法满足越来越多的性能功耗
和集成度的需求
因此在移动终端的领域
必须在摩尔定律之外
探索新的技术路径
在摩尔定律放缓的时代
从平面走向堆叠
是重要的技术发展方向
也就是所谓的先进封装
在产业界已经形成了一些成熟的技术方案
这些方案都在各自的应用场景取得了成功
譬如说高频宽记忆体HBM
透过储存堆叠显著的提升了频宽密度
而互补型金属氧化物半导体的影像感测器
CIS堆叠
实现了画素阵列
和逻辑的分层优化
此外三维快取记忆体3D cache
堆叠在处理器的上方
则透过快取堆叠
提升了特定运算场景下的效能和能源效率
但是呢
这些方案大多是属于相对固定的结构
以及出力度的方式来进行堆叠
他们的互联密度
设计自由度和逻辑拆分能力
仍然非常有限
什么叫做晶片设计的出力度
我们后面会和大家解释
所以这一段文字的意思就是
在过去工业上已经证明的3D堆叠封装
也就是把晶片垂直堆叠起来
主要有三个发展方向
第一种是高频宽记忆体HBM
将记忆体控制器的逻辑晶片放在最下面
同时在上面堆叠许多动态随机存取记忆体的晶片
这种连接方式是属于
晶片堆叠晶圆
Di2Wafer
它的讯号连接数量
可以达到大约1万
也就是垂直方向
有1万个金属柱互相连接
因此高频宽记忆体HBM
是将许多动态随机存取
记忆体晶片垂直堆叠
在记忆体控制晶片的上方
这个称为3D封装
同时将处理器和记忆体
左右堆叠在细中介板上
这个称为2.5D封装
第二种是影像感测器CIS
将讯号处理器的逻辑晶片放在下面
将影像感测器晶片放在上面
并且垂直堆叠起来
这种连结形式称为晶圆堆叠晶圆
Wafer to Wafer
它的讯号连结数量可以达到大约10万
也就是垂直方向有10万个金属柱互相连接
这个就是影像感测器的晶圆堆叠晶圆
Wave on Weave
最上面的晶片是影像感测器
中间的晶片是动态随机存取记忆体
当影像感测器接收外面传送过来的影像
将光讯号转成电讯号
就可以暂时储存在动态随机存取记忆体
DRAIN里面
最后再送到第三层晶片进行数位逻辑运算
左边这个是电子显微镜的剖面图
最上面这一个晶片是影像感测元件
中间这个晶片是动态随机存取记忆体
BRAP下面这个晶片是数位逻辑运算用的晶片
将这三个晶片垂直堆叠起来
经由细穿孔连接这三层晶片
右边这个则是光学显微镜的照片
可以看出最上面是影像感测器
中间是动态随机存取记忆体
使用30nm的制程
最下面是数位逻辑运算晶片
使用40nm的制程
第三种是快取记忆体堆叠
将快取记忆体放在下面
处理器放在上面
或者导过来将处理器放在下面
快取记忆体放在上面
垂直堆叠起来
这种连接形式称为
晶片堆叠晶圆
Di2Wafer
它的讯号连接数量
可以达到大约10万
也就是垂直方向
有大约10万个金属柱
互相连接
这个就是AMD
使用台积电的3D封装技术
进行小晶片封装
上面这个就是快取记忆体的精力
下面这个则是最多八核心的核心复合晶片CCD
也就是处理器运算晶片
中间透过细穿孔进行细晶片对细晶片的通讯
使用直接同对同的连接技术
将快取记忆体小晶片堆叠在处理器小晶片的上方
这三种传统的晶片堆叠技术存在许多限制
包括精力对精力之间的互联密度不容易提升
以及晶片设计的力度和灵活性不高
以及功耗效率面积的效益受到限制
而它的优势在于功耗效率面积成本
PPA-C适合系统单晶片
而且可以大量生产
接下来我们和大家介绍传统先进封装
采用2D平面设计思维
过去电子设计自动化工具
EDA2O都是基于平面细致
进行布局和绕线
也就是同一个区块是同一个细致材
因此是属于2D平面的设计思维
数位机体电路的设计流程
包括系统设计
System Design
逻辑设计Logical Design
又称为前段设计
实体设计Physical Design
又称为后段设计
完成设计之后
称为流片
Tab Hub
进行光照制作和半导体制成
最后再进行封装和测试
而系统设计主要是进行市场规格制定
系统规格制定
功能规格制定与区块规格制定
这里的区块就是
机体电路设计的一个小单位
在晶片设计中所谓的力度指的就是把一个晶片的功能拆分成许多小块的细字材来设计
或者细字材的结构有多细微
因此所谓的粗力度是指把面积很大或者功能很完整的细字材
例如整个处理器的核心
甚至整个处理器包成一个大细致材来使用
这样做的好处是开发快速设计简单
而所谓的细粒度是指把晶片功能拆分的非常细
分成许多很小的逻辑单元
虽然设计和布局的难度变高
但是能够让晶片更紧凑
节省空间并且大幅缩短讯号传播的延迟
因此在过去晶片的设计是使用粗粒度的方式
来进行堆叠
也就是把面积很大或者功能完整的细制材
当成一个整体来设计晶片
再经由先进封装堆叠起来
这也是目前包含台积电在内
世界各地先进制程的晶圆场
最常使用的一种方式
而这种粗力度设计晶片的方式
互联密度设计自由度和逻辑拆分的能力有限
因此过去传统先进封装是使用2D平面的设计思维采用粗粒度的方式来设计晶片也就是把面积很大或者功能很完整的细致材设计成一个晶片再将许多晶片垂直堆叠
起来不管用哪一种3D封装的形式
他在设计上都是属于2D平面设计思维
而Talding律是使用细粒度的细致材
因此是属于3D立体的设计思维
也就是所谓的逻辑折叠Logic Folding
将实体逻辑切分成微小的单元
并且分配到不同的细晶片上
换句话说
把原来在同一个晶片上的微小单元切割开来
分别放到不同的晶片上
再利用先进封装把晶片堆叠起来
因此是属于3D立体的设计思维
利用上下两层晶片的结构
来寻找逻辑连线的最短路径
这样就可以降低系统各层的特征时间长数
达到缩短时间长速
How 的目的
未来半导体产业的竞争核心
将不再只是谁能够做出更小的电晶体
而是谁能够以最有效率的方式来压缩时间
但是要达到这个目的
必须修改电子设计自动化工具
EDA Tool 的软体
以及细致材IP设计和授权的概念
同时还要跟晶圆制程先进封装紧密配合
对实体电路的布局和绕线
时迈路径必须进行极度精细的优化
才能突破传统2D平面设计思维的性能限制
这个图就是华为涛定律细立度细致材
采用3D立体设计思维的示意图
在这个图里面大家可以看出
将同一个晶片切割成不同的逻辑单元
并且布局在下面和上面两个不同的晶片
再利用先进封装正面对正面堆叠起来
这样就可以缩短电讯号的传送路径
在这个图里面的COMB指的应该是组合逻辑
包含逻辑杂编码器多工器等等
而FF指的应该是循序逻辑的正反器
计数器拴锁器等等
同时也必须将时脈切分成上晶片和下晶片
因此设计的困难度大幅提升
上面的晶片依照半导体制成的精度要求
可能必须达到快速快速 fast fast
下面的晶片
根据半导体制成精度的要求
可能必须达到缓慢缓慢 slow slow
换句话说
将一个晶片的功能切割成更小的逻辑单元
再将不同的逻辑单元分配在上面的晶片和下面的晶片
利用先进封装的方式堆叠起来
寻找最小的讯号传递路径
会比把所有的逻辑单元都放在同一个晶片
缩短距离
这样就可以增加工作的频率
缩短时间长数
这样的技术称为逻辑折叠Logic Folding
采用高密度的晶圆对晶圆
Waver to Waver
与正面对正面Face to Face的先进封装
并且利用混合建核Hybrid Bounding
和背面的细穿孔TSV技术来进行晶片的堆叠
透过超高密度的垂直互联
实现高效自由的逻辑设计
这样必须实现良好的混合建核的建具
以及顶层金属之间的散出比
也就是具有更多的垂直金属连线
使得细粒度的拆分成为可能
为设计带来巨大的灵活性
而且逻辑折叠以后的系统单晶片架构图
在折叠以后的上层晶片和下层晶片
不再有独立的模组纸系统
而是上下层透过大量互联的金属导线
形成模组纸系统
也就是上面的晶片和下面的晶片
必须进行大量的垂直金属连接
而且上下层的晶片不再是独立的晶片
而是一个晶片不可分割的一部分
它还能比较方便的来实现上下层晶片的通讯
才能缩短时间长数掏
大家要记得目前的数位机体电路
不同层的金属导线具有不同的粗细
在细晶片上先成长电晶体
接下来再用数十层的金属导线连接电晶体
其中最下面的金属导线属于区域连线
粗细大约几十奈米
中间的金属导线属于中间连线
粗细大约几百奈米
上面的金属导线属于全域连线
粗细大约几微米
而依照逻辑折叠的设计模式
上下层的晶片是属于细粒度的逻辑单元
因此必须使用区域连线
来连结上下两个不同的晶片
连线的数目会远大于传统的3D封装
而且这些区域连线
导线很细
又不能使用中介版
该如何实现呢
华为这一次所提出的逻辑折叠
有赖于非常精密的先进封装技术
才能堆叠上下两个细利度的逻辑单元
而这一次华为发表的论文
提到逻辑折叠
在行动系统单晶片
SOC的验证案例
也就是手机的晶片
这个图的横轴是时间维度
在元件上距离很近
大约是匹秒到耐秒的时间
在电路上距离比较远
大约是耐秒到微秒的时间
在晶片上距离更远
大概是微秒到毫秒的时间
在系统上距离最远
大约是毫秒到秒的时间
和逻辑折叠的实现
必须使用晶圆对晶圆
Wafer to wafer
以及正面对正面
Face to face
并且以混合建核 Hybrid Bonding的方式连接上下两个晶片
而且上下两个晶片是属于细立度的逻辑单元
进行高密度的垂直连线
因此华为所使用的技术
必须满足用于逻辑折叠和更高电晶体密度的超高密度
晶圆对晶圆混合建核技术
必须系统性的最小化混合建核和顶部金属的散出比
也就是具有更多的垂直金属连线
同时必须满足细粒度的逻辑分区
来减少连线长度
降低电阻电容的寄生参数
而TAU定律里面的时间长数TAU
被视为一种分层结构
在每一个层级中都存在不同的机制
可用来降低时间长数TAU
包括电晶体层、电路层、晶片层和系统层
第一个电晶体层的时间长数
称为TAU Transistor
要缩短电晶体层的时间长速
可以透过提升载质迁移率材料应变工程
也就是使用电子电动迁移率高的材料
或者材料应变工程
也就是改变材料的结构
或者使用高界电长速
金属杂集HIKMETALGATE的技术
或者使用环绕杂集GAA的架构
来降低内在的切换延迟
更重要的是要降低局部连线
所造成的寄生电阻和寄生电容
第二个电路层的时间长速
称为TOWCICUIT
可以降低讯号路径中的电阻电容传播延迟
主要的手段包括使用较低电阻的导电材料
或使用低界电长速LOK的绝缘材料
这种材料不容易吸引电子电动
就可以增加电子电动移动的速度
或者透过垂直整合缩短导线长度
其中最后一项通常具有最显著的效果
也就是这一次华为提出逻辑折叠所使用的技术
利用上下两个晶片来缩短导线的长度
第三个是晶片层的时间长数
称为Touchip
主要关注运算延迟和记忆体存取延迟
优化的方式包括架构设计的改变
或者流水线的深度变化
或者记忆体阶层以及晶片内互联网络的改变
第四个是系统层的时间长数
称为Touch System
主要的目标是降低端到端的讯息传播和同步时间
相关的手段包括改变个层晶片之间的互联托谱
或是改变通讯协定的堆叠
或是改变系统互联网络的设计
而逻辑折叠的制程挑战包括混合建核
必须做到无系统等级的冗余
还有高粮绿的建核以及晶圆平整度和高精度的对准
意思就是上下两个晶片因为是属于相邻的逻辑单元因此必须用尺寸比较小的金属导线垂直连接在平面上必须非常的平整
才能无缝连接
在垂直方向上必须左右对准
才能精准的连接
因此细穿孔制成的能力也变得很重要
必须制作高深宽笔的背面细穿孔
而且晶片堆叠必须磨薄
因此必须解决超薄无损伤的细薄化硬力
另外对于封装的影响
必须留意细穿孔排除区域
也就是从2D的设计思维变成3D的设计思维
必须考虑细穿孔排除区域
并且要解决热硬力和晶圆薄化的硬力
华为先进的混合建核技术
源自于需求是创新之母
华为2026年的麒麟晶片
将采用1.5微米建核建具的3D堆叠架构
2027年麒麟晶片的建核建具
将会进一步缩小到1微米
而台积电才刚迈入6微米的系统堆叠整合晶片SOIC时代
下一步计划在2030年推出4.5微米的产品
而Intel推出的Volvirus Direct
在2026年制作的Clear Water Forest的晶片
可以达到9微米的建核建具
这里的消息来源来自于Semi-Ansis
关键在于台积电和Intel可以用先进制程来缩小电晶体的尺寸
因此先进封装就不需要这么细小的线路
而华为因为没有极止外光的技术去缩小电晶体
反而强迫它必须发展更先进的先进封装技术
制作尺寸更小的金属导线
所以才说需求是创新之母
华为更高的混合建核互联密度
会使得逻辑折叠的设计成为可能
能够对晶片进行更精细的架构划分
同时优化布线缩短关键路径
也就是将同一个晶片上的逻辑单元
拆分成上下两个晶片
再利用先进封装混合建核的技术堆叠起来
当混合建核的建具比较大的时候
金属导线的关键路径就比较长
因此华为必须开发小于2微米的混合建核建具
当混合建核建具缩小的时候
导线的关键路径就可以缩短
这个是新的散出闭合方法
而逻辑折叠从概念走向真实晶片
还面临系统的挑战
不仅来自于自成制造的复杂度
也来自于设计方法学
和电子设计自动化工具的不成熟
或者说根本目前就没有现成可用的工具
应该需要很多年才会有好用的工具列
现在的工作是必须在完善工具
不成熟的条件下完成开发
特别是设计流程和方法学是逻辑折叠遇到最大的挑战
从平面设计思维转向立体设计思维
不再有成熟的工具链来支持
传统的电子设计自动化工具流程也难以直接扩展到折叠空间
传统的设计流程通常默认设计对象主要是在一个平面上
因此工具优化的目标也是单晶片内的持续功耗和布线拥挤问题
但是逻辑折叠的设计对象变成多个垂直堆叠的设计混合建核和细穿孔互联
因此跨晶片的时序路径跨晶片的电源网路跨晶片的热偶等等问题都必须解决
换句话说华为必须和合作厂商配合共同开发新的电子设计自动化工具
而逻辑折叠计流程和方法论面临的挑战
包括逻辑折叠对电路板等级的影响
在关键步骤必须进行细利度的分割
也就是将一个晶片分割成许多逻辑单元
而且必须具有更好的功耗效能面积
以及更高的复杂度
再加上多阶段迭代实现多目标的设计收敛
以及增强电子设计自动化工具的功能
数位机体电路的逻辑设计
必须先进行暂存器转换阶层执行与发展RTL
完成后进行功能模拟
以及现场可程式化逻辑杂阵列验证
如果错误就修改程式
如果正确得到的结果
称为 RTL
又称为软体细制裁Soft IP
接下来进行逻辑合成和功能在模拟
如果错误就修改逻辑
如果正确得到的结果
称为Netlist
又称为韧体细制裁FNIP
数位机体电路的实体设计
包括平面配置
自动布局与绕线
以及设计规则检查
与电路图对比验证
如果错误则修改线路
如果正确的结果称为GDS2
又称为硬体细制材HOT IP
因此华为提出的逻辑折叠设计流程
必须修改电子设计自动化工具来配合
包括架构的设计
以及暂存器转换阶层的配合
更重要的是实体设计
必须将一个晶片里面的逻辑单元
进行区块分割
并且将不同的逻辑单元
分别配置到两个不同的晶片上
再经由先进封装垂直堆叠起来
因此区块分割是逻辑折叠技术
和传统晶片设计最大的差别
接下来还要经过合成平面配置
布局时迈速合成绕线
一直到最后完成机体电路的迁合
包括静态时序分析
STA 电源完整性 PI 讯号完整性 SI
日程电压 PV 和散热相关的铅盒
必须经过多晶片共同优化电路
并且将设计过程进行迭代和最佳化
考量包括面积混合建核时序
电源散热
电源完整性
讯号完整性以及良率
因此前面我们提到
逻辑折叠必须将时脈分配到上晶片
和下晶片
因此逻辑折叠时迈收敛会遇到的挑战
包括增加静态时序分析
STA 的制程角复杂度
由晶片交叉的制程电压温度PVT组合
会引起时迈偏移
和资料路径延迟变化的增加
必须进行多制程角组合
而且必须开发晶片间
时迈偏移最小化的技术
顶层晶片的时迈数
必须透过混合建核
直接连接底层晶片的节点
必须能够开发出上晶片
时麦网状网路
和下晶片区域最小时麦数
同时由于逻辑折叠
堆叠晶片会造成散热困难的问题
因此逻辑折叠必须进行散热管理
由于逻辑折叠将一个晶片上的电晶体
切割成更小的逻辑单元
变成上下两个晶片垂直堆叠
因此逻辑折叠技术提高了功率密度
同时晶圆减薄也造成横向热扩散减小
这些都是必须解决的散热问题
可能的解决方法
包括采用热杆之分区布局配置的方式
也就是将不同的发热区域分散配置
或是降低风值功率密度
并且避免热点重叠
也就是不要让上下两个晶片的热点重叠
或是改善封装级的散热设计
从右边这个图可以看出
横轴是时间
纵轴是晶片的温度
使用传统的2D晶片设计思维
随着时间增加
晶片的温度也会增加
使用3D封装的晶片堆叠
随着时间增加
温度也会增加
而使用逻辑折叠
再加上封装的优化
可以看出红色这一条曲线
当时间增加初期温度会增加
而温度增加是小于2D的设计思维
到后期温度增加
甚至会小于3D的晶片堆叠
另外逻辑折叠必须设计全新的电源递送方式
包括复杂的电源递送网络
在顶层的金属上面这个图是传统2D的电源和接地
这里的TM1和TM2是顶部金属
而逻辑折叠的电源和接地在水平方向
必须使用讯号网状网络
而垂直方向必须使用讯号混合键合
针对电力和讯号混合键合
以及网状网路的大规模混合建合将资源最佳化同时也必须考虑到顶部和底部的电源功率由于逻辑折叠将同一个晶片上的逻辑单元
分散到上下两个晶片
因此必须考虑水平的电源递送网路
以及多功率领域的细穿孔
在投影区域内功率领域的复杂度会增加
另外还必须特别进行电源完整性牵合
必须考量到上下两个晶片的电源传送路径
电源递送网路必须综合建模
同时要支援电子设计自动化工具的全晶片
电源完整性牵合
最后华为这个报告提到逻辑折叠的晶片密度改善
特别强调目前全球领先的晶圆厂
在2020年发展5奈米制程
在2023年发展3奈米制程
电晶体密度变成1.3倍
在2026年发展2奈米制程
电晶体密度变成1.5倍
到2029年发展1.4奈米制程
电晶体密度变成1.8倍
而华为使用逻辑折叠
在2025年发展5奈米制程
到2026年使用逻辑折叠
可以将等效电晶体密度变成1.6倍
在2027年可以将等效电晶体密度变成1.7倍
在2029年可以将等效电晶体密度变成1.8倍
华为用这个图就是说明
使用逻辑折叠
在2029年可以开发出等效5奈米制成1.8倍的电晶体密度
就好像领先的晶圆厂
在2029年开发出1.4奈米是5奈米的1.8倍
事实上华为计算等效电晶体密度
是将两个晶片堆叠之后的面积当成一个晶片来计算
我认为这个计算没有意义
事实上华为这一次提出了很好的观点
就是未来的半导体产业竞争核心
不再是谁能做出更小的电晶体
而是谁能以最有效率的方式压缩时间
因此我认为华为不应该再去计算
所谓的等效电晶体密度
来和其他的晶圆场对比
而是应该开发出新的时间常数量测方法
作为不同晶圆场之间制成对比的方式
这里华为特别强调
超高密度晶圆对晶圆的堆叠
可以让晶片密度提升60%
互联技术规模化
可以推动电晶体密度的成长
以及逻辑折叠技术的优势
有效抵消了摩尔定律放缓的影响
最后谈到逻辑折叠的性能和能源效率的提升
因为电晶体密度提高
促进了维架构最佳化和并行扩展
同时也减少互联的电阻电容效应
这样就会使得处理器的效能提升
包括单核心中央处理器效能提升
15%到44%
中央处理器多核心效能提升
24%到56%
图形处理器效能提升38%到87%
神经处理器效能提升140%到213%
同时也达成能源效率的提升
中央处理器单核心能源效率提升12%到34%
以及图形处理器能源效率提升40%到78%
神经处理器能源效率提升81%到118%
在这一次的发表会
华为也提到数位讯号处理器的应用实例
可以进行资料路径的提升
缩短记忆体存取的距离
提升模组区域化
左边这个图是2D平面设计思维
1号路径包括红色的570微米
和黄色的676微米
2号路径是681微米
使用逻辑折叠分成上晶片和下晶片
1号路径包括红色的缩短到10微米
而且是经由上下垂直系穿孔达成
黄色的缩短到307微米
二号路径缩短到458微米
证明逻辑折叠使功率效能面积提升
包括晶片的面积缩小40%
时迈增加37%
总功耗降低24%
同时经由逻辑折叠
可以达成时迈路径的提升
可以减少时迈数的拓展
同时让时迈数的结构平坦
左边这个图是2D平面设计思维
最大时迈偏移为135pc
经由逻辑折叠之后的最大时迈偏移
缩小到101psec
因此逻辑折叠可以使时迈速的功能改善
最后探讨逻辑折叠的成本和良率效益
逻辑折叠之后的良率
相当于要计算上晶片的良率
下晶片的良率
以及混合建合的良率
在晶片尺寸缩小
单晶片的良率可以提高
因此整体良率可以达到2D晶片的水准
而优化的3D堆叠制程
必须要达成可忽略不计的良率损失
再透过系统优化的设计来进一步提高良率
事实上使用逻辑折叠在制成良率上会面临困难
因此必须具备高水准的先进封装技术
最后的结论是经由逻辑折叠可以达成
更高的电晶体密度和功率效能面积PPA增加
为行动领域创造新的扩展机会
同时互联规模会持续扩大
进一步扩展潜在的效率
发展逻辑折叠必须持续的开发电子设计自动化工具的功能提升
提高效率并且实现更高的整体效益
终极的目标就是逻辑折叠达到超定率的成功实现
最后我们来看一下华为海斯麒麟晶片的产品路线图
这一代的混合建核建具必须做到小于2微米
量产板要小于1.5微米
目标齿轮比1
套科精度要小于0.5微米
也就是上下对准的精度
细穿孔的规格包含关键尺寸
排除区域要小于1.5微米
间距要小于6微米
核心的能效必须提升41%
主要工作频率要提升13%
时迈缓冲器数量减少50%
时迈偏移减少25%
布线长度减少30%
从下面这个表可以看出
2023、2024、2025年开发的麒麟处理器
都是使用2D平面设计思维
工作频率从2.6到2.75GHz
目前都已经量产
2026年开始
麒麟系列处理器
使用逻辑折叠技术
工作频率达到3.1GHz
2027年工作频率达到3.39GHz
目前已经在细晶片验证阶段
2028年工作频率达到3.71GHz
2029年工作频率达到4GHz
目前在前细晶片验证阶段
也就是晶片设计当中
欢迎加入知识力专业社群
你的专属科技顾问
经由前面的介绍
大家会发现这一次华为提出的掏定率
在先进制程缩小越来越困难的状况下
舍弃电晶体密度改用时间长数来判断制程进步的程度
其实是一个很好的观点
因此华为的掏定率确实有创新之处
只是文章的后面为了要和其他的晶圆场比较
却又走回头路计算等效电晶体密度
我个人觉得其实并不必要
在先进制程缩小越来越困难的情况下
或许未来的先进制程改用计算时间长速的方式来判断先进制程进步的程度
也是一个方法
至于华为今年下半年要量产的麒麟晶片
是不是真的可以和台积电的3奈米制程对比呢
我觉得不需要计算等效电晶体密度
可以等将来晶片生产之后
直接用跑分的方式就可以做出精准的比较
或是华为也可以提出一套特别的时间长速测试方法
一般晶圆场要比较先进制程的进步程度
是直接使用电子显微镜量测关键尺寸
或许华为也可以考虑设计一套时间常数的量测方法
作为未来先进制程比较的基准
那么你认为今年下半年华为量产的麒麟晶片
实际的运算效能能够挑战台积电吗
把你的想法留言告诉我们
好我们今天的节目就到这边
大家对于先进制程和时间常数有任何相关的问题
歡迎大家發表在影片的下方
我們再來討論
謝謝大家
晚安
掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive